we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P I think it's sort of in
reaction to the Kanye West anti-Semitism
controversy I got an interesting email
take a listen to this
hey David it's James again I was just
wondering uh do you think that most
anti-Semitism comes from people who
don't know any Jews
um because I I don't know a whole lot of
juices
um but the ones that I had met are
really lovely people I I say they're
more christ-like
then probably more Christians than I met
um
yeah so do you think it's because they
don't know any Jews or because they do
know Jews and don't like them
so the thing about I I've met lots of
people in my life who when they find out
I'm Jewish they go I've never met a
Jewish person before
it's almost always
they've never met a Jewish person that
they were aware of but like most people
unless you live in extremely rural
places you have certain parts of the
country
it's just not obvious like you know when
you meet a black person you can tell
that they're black
um so when people say oh I've never met
a Jewish person it's actually you
probably just didn't realize it now from
to this to this question is the
anti-Semitism because these folks have
never met a Jewish person or they didn't
didn't like them I don't think it's
related at all to personal experience in
many ways for most of the folks that
I've met it's based on stories that they
heard over and over and over again as
they were growing up regardless of who
they personally knew that's my that's my
sense that's my instinct we have a great
bonus show for you today just me on the
bonus show today producer Pat a little
bit under the weather he'll be back very
soon we will talk about
it's happening again
40 of Republicans say they will blame
election fraud if they don't win
they're already saying if we don't win
we're going to blame election fraud also
big problems for Electric Vehicle
Manufacturer rivian
who has had almost had to recall almost
all of their electric trucks
not good and we will talk about upcoming
debates the Spanish Channel
possibilities that are being discussed
and many many more things get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up
at joinpakman.com it's quick it's easy
you can use the coupon code big voting22
the meaning should be obvious as we are
just weeks away from the midterms big
voting 22 at joinpakman.com